i have this uh student her name is
denira and she lives in la single mom
three kids really small house not enough
rooms for everybody like she is
definitely doing it her herself she was
working two jobs and she was baking and
people would come to her house they'd
pick up a birthday cake or a celebration
cake or whatever and that's how one way
she was making money long story short
cut to creating a digital course and she
became really good at caramel candy
apples so how to create caramel candy
apples and the thing is the caramel was
store-bought it wasn't like her special
recipe just people didn't know what
store to go to or what to buy and so she
started to create these and
sell a digital course now a lot of my
students many of them have made seven
figures and beyond but i want to talk
about her because she's a woman who made
um never made over a hundred thousand
dollars a year and now in one digital
course launch she made 260 000
selling how to create uh caramel candy
apples and she literally was just doing
live videos in a private facebook group
and i always tell that story because a
lot of people listening have never
created anything in their life online
and they would never even they're like
my idea can't be good enough or it's not
original enough or whatever and then i
think of daenerys single mom living in
la making 260 000 on the first time she
launched anything now she's making way
more money than that but that's the kind
of stuff that i live for because it has
to start somewhere
[Music]
so amy what's going on so amy
porterfield you're you're part of the
hubspot podcast network you're a newish
addition right once you join right uh
yeah just about two months
um
and so what would you say you do i mean
you do a i've read your blog for years
and years and years but we had john lee
dumas on the other day and i was like i
actually don't know how to describe him
and he's like is he do i just call him a
podcaster is he
he's a blogger i'm not actually sure
what how i would like because you kind
of do a bunch of stuff how would you
describe i sound like my mom and dad who
have no clue what i do 13 years in so i
totally get it i always say that i am an
internet marketing expert and i help
entrepreneurs still build businesses
online and my expertise is to take your
knowledge and know-how and turn that
into a profitable digital course so
digital courses are my area of expertise
online okay amazing what kind of digital
courses do you have your own course
about courses
i do which is so meta i know so
basically here's the thing uh 13 years
ago i worked in corporate i worked for
tony robbins and i was the director of
content development got to travel the
world and work on content that tony did
on stage at like unleash the power
within and date with destiny and all
those cool events
and i was in a meeting
and i was called so humbling i was
called into this meeting to take notes
and i walk into this meeting in this big
san diego corporate office and i walk in
and it's a bunch of internet marketers
now in my world these are like the
grandfather of internet marketers
although that sounds very rude to to
call them grandfathers but they're like
the mack daddies so it's like frank kern
brendan bouchard evan pagan jeff walker
like big name internet marketers that
are still doing really big things but
they were the leaders in the industry i
had no idea who these guys were and here
i am at a side table taking notes and
tony's going around asking them about
their businesses and what do they do and
how are they making money online and all
i heard was freedom like these guys were
running their own businesses creating
digital courses about tons of different
topics and i wanted a piece of that so
that was like my first entry into this
world i knew nothing about
and about six months later or so i had
left my corporate job and started
creating my own digital courses so yeah
i've got digital courses teaching people
how to grow email lists how to create
digital courses but ultimately my my
mission is to help people leave their
nine to five jobs start their own online
businesses and i believe digital courses
is a way to do that so that's their
vehicle sean you have something to say
because i i i just
i just say forget courses let's talk
about tony robbins i was gonna say that
exact same thing i was gonna i was gonna
say uh i was gonna ask you about a
couple of the people you mentioned
including tony and i was like
how much does this empire bring in you
think is does this guy just knock it out
the park or what
i mean it's seriously what i always say
about tony is how if have you guys ever
been to one of his events before have
you ever seen him on stage i've been to
two actually i've been to yeah i've been
to two unleash the power within uh okay
cool and i'm a kool-aid drinker i love
tony robbins
absolutely yeah so i'm a fan but i'm
also super curious i don't know the guy
or know much about him
so i'm still a fan after all these years
and how he is on stage like that huge
personality all the energy super intense
like how he is on stage is exactly how
he is behind stage as well i often joke
that i might have lost a few years off
my life because that was the most
intense job i ever had but i wouldn't
change it for the world because i
literally got to learn from the master
give me an intensity story tony robbins
intensity i love what you got so the
thing is when before tony the beans
wait what you gotta spill the beans you
gotta
tell us the stories
here's why it's intense before he goes
on stage he literally preps for
uh unleash the power within like it's
the first time he ever stepped on stage
i've never seen anyone prep for anything
and be prepared more in my entire life
and so we have to write these like stage
signs of everything that like he's going
to talk about and the stories he's gonna
touch on and they're all um handwritten
i don't know why we would hand write
these things every time but they're
handwritten and he goes over all of them
and then he gets on this rebounder and
he's jumping on the rebounder behind
stage getting all the energy in his body
the moment
what's a rebounder it's like a
trampoline trampoline like a trampoline
yeah
yeah and it kind of gets the energy
going in your body and he's reading your
stage sign and making sure he's got
everything going and then he just throws
the stage sign and he runs on stage and
he does his thing but the intense part
is when he gets off he looks at who's
ever in his proximity and he's like all
right let's download he downloads every
single time he comes off stage what
worked what didn't it what we could make
better what he liked what he didn't like
he wants feedback from everyone and it's
like you are on the entire time i still
i'm nervous talking about it yeah you
sound like it so he's been doing this
for like 40 years that's crazy to me
because i went to the two things and he
does the same exact thing right he does
pretty much the same script so i i would
assume he's like you know
knows it by the back of his you know
like like the back of his hand or
whatever by now
um so it's not it's probably not the
material that he's like trying to
remember it's like he's just getting
himself into that state what about
exactly what about besides the
performances i think performing is
definitely like a high intensity thing
what about just like work like the
office or were you not around for that
part
uh meaning tony in the office yeah just
like on a normal day non-performance
so on a normal day non-performance
tony's not in the office he was when i
was there he was at his house he did all
the stuff from his own house but he's
always on so i think one thing i took
what i learned from tony and i brought
into my own business is that one always
be prepared over prepare care deeply
about what you're creating he cares
deeply about his content so that's why
he's always getting it in his body even
though we've done it a hundred times
and when he's not in the office he's
still always always learning always
meeting with people learning new things
like that meeting that we had he just
wanted to know how they were selling
their digital courses online because he
was gonna start doing that in a bigger
way so he's always pulling from
different places it was an incredible
experience
what about uh so sean i've told you
about this guy before his name's eben
pagan and we talked we're sean and i amy
are good friends with um
craig clemons
and he was a copywriter and when we had
john lee dumas on the other day
i was like john tell me about some of
these marketers they're so fascinating
to me and you just named a bunch of them
and i'm going to ask you i want to ask
you about them but evan pagan's the most
interesting so basically for the
listeners edmond pagan i knew him as
david d'angelo when i was 14 years old i
was a nerd i wanted to learn how to meet
girls he had an e-book called double
your dating and what he would do if i
remember correctly and amy you could
correct me i think he would if he would
send these really long emails like it
felt like 10 000 word text based emails
about how to meet women and at the end
you could buy like a 14 book
and i think craig told us that he was
selling like 30 million dollars a year
of this book on called double your
dating have you heard about this
yo absolutely i've heard about it and i
know he's a legend in in that area and
when he came to the table i think he had
moved on from um that part of his
business but that's how he was put on
the map and the one thing that i learned
from evan really early on is he teaches
the strategy that you've got to coin
your own content like you've got to name
it you've got to put a
title to it you've got to own it so one
of the things that i've always done when
i've created content in my own business
is like i've got the portafilled process
for outlining your digital course and
the sweet spot for finding what topic to
create for your your course i name
everything and own it and it sets you up
as an expert and that absolutely came
from ebay it's like
so me and sam both teach courses on
maven and
wes who runs the the course platform for
maven she she has one that she calls
she's like you need your spiky point of
view it's like what what's your spiky
point of view and she's like it's a
point of view that stands out that not
everybody would agree with it's like
it'll poke some people the wrong way
uh because it's different than you know
everything that they've heard before and
so you know that was like the core of
when she's like if you're gonna teach a
course you've got to have a spiky point
of view otherwise like your course
doesn't really have a a sort of angle to
it or a hook to it um that you that
other people are going to attach with
yeah i love that do you um
the other day sean and i were talking
about this guy named sam evans because
he he had this youtube video called
consul uh he has a business called
consulting.com and he revealed all of
his numbers and he was like we got to 30
million in revenue and then we decided
to just be really profitable and we do
10 million in sales with five million in
profit with like a team of four people
and we were just fascinated because
that's just like a that's a great great
business to own that um what are some
other people who who you've worked with
or that you know of that are like
shockingly
that you would tell people and you're
like i can you not believe what this
person does you would not believe how
much revenue they make or that they sell
a course uh in this space are there any
shocking ones like that
so one of the ones that always has
shocked me i have this uh student her
name is denira and she lives in la
single mom three kids really small house
not enough rooms for everybody like she
is definitely doing it her herself she
was working two jobs and she um was
baking and people would come to her
house they'd pick up a birthday cake or
a celebration cake or whatever and
that's how one way she was making money
long story short cut to creating a
digital course and she became really
good at caramel candy apples so how to
create caramel candy apples and the
thing is the caramel was store-bought it
wasn't like her special recipe just
people didn't know what store to go to
or what to buy and so she started to
create these and
sell a digital course now a lot of my
students many of them have made seven
figures and beyond but i want to talk
about her because she's a woman who made
um never made over a hundred thousand
dollars a year and now in one digital
course launch she made 260 000
selling how to create uh caramel candy
apples and she literally was just doing
live videos in a private facebook group
and i always tell that story because a
lot of people listening have never
created anything in their life online
and they would never even they're like
my idea can't be good enough or it's not
original enough or whatever and then i
think of denira single mom living in la
making 260 000 on the first time she
launched anything now she's making way
more money than that but that's the kind
of stuff that i live for because it has
to start somewhere what's her course
name how do i google her
um let's see if you did google de nira
caramel candy apples you will absolutely
find her i spelled daenerys
d-a-n-i-r-a
we call her the caramel candy apple
queen she's got tons of press written up
about her like she's she's a big deal
how did she get her customers so who
bought this course how did she go sell
how much is the course
uh i can't remember a couple hundred
dollars okay and the way she got her
customers this is what's cool she made a
lot of videos she did a lot of social
media where she'd show in her tiny
little kitchen with not a fancy camera
or lighting like what she was doing and
the thing is so if you own a bakery a
caramel candy apple is like 10 bucks or
more
to sell which is really good profit for
a bakery and these bakers wanted to find
more ways to make more money so she app
she appealed to the
small business owners who had bakeries
or sweets to sell but she also appealed
to a lot of hobbyists a lot of people
are like i just want to do that that's
cool so she had a mesh of two different
audiences but her she basically just
made free content
and then tons of content lots of videos
yep wow and then the way i teach people
how to sell courses is with webinars so
she she started to do webinars and
webinars were away a new vehicle to sell
more so she's gone on to do even more
launches you would do a webinar for a
three or two hundred dollar thing
absolutely so back in the day my very
first successful course was called fb
influence i did it with lewis howes and
together we created this course and
launched it was 97
and i probably did 200 webinars to sell
a 97 course and it was a huge success
because we had tons of affiliates but i
would do a webinar even for a 97 course
amongst these internet marketers who
what's the largest
course i don't know a course info
product what's the largest business
you've ever heard of
oh geez the largest business i've ever
heard of
um
[Music]
i don't know i feel like people
yeah who crushes it the most that's a
that's a that's a different way to vote
well
my girl marie forleo do you guys know
marie forleo she has a program called
b-school she's been crushing it for 10
years here's what's unique about her
course she's had the same course
obviously she makes it a little bit
better every year makes the marketing
better but it's literally the same
course that she has sold for i think 13
years now once a year she sells this
course two thousand dollars now it's
2500. um but she's in the game been in
the game for 13 years with the same
course that to me is badass because
she's probably made like three million
dollars a year in profit for like 10
years would you you think that's crazy
yes i do she's very quiet about her
dollars so i don't know exactly but i've
seen the numbers the affiliates i've
been an affiliate for a really long time
absolutely she's crushing it and the
thing is and what i learned from tony
robbins is you do not always want to
reinvent the wheel find something that
works double down on it and stop
starting from scratch all the time and
that's literally what marie has mastered
so she's someone that i've always
followed from the get-go is there anyone
else
um i'm trying to think it's just that
here's the thing sometimes i don't think
people are totally forthcoming with
their numbers i've been in the internet
marketing space for a long time and
sometimes i trust you know what i hear
and sometimes i don't and sometimes
people throw out numbers and i'm like
yeah but what's the profit margin on
that so i always am a little bit uh
unsure about what the numbers really are
the affiliate strategy so uh what
because i think most people if they're
like oh i'm gonna create my own first my
first course they wouldn't think that oh
i should be using affiliate strategy so
explain what that works and how big of a
tool that is for for you and your like
marketing magics do you use that even do
you even use that sean do you use
affiliates
no
so i have made millions in my own
business be an affiliate for other
people but i've also had affiliates sell
my own courses and to me i think it's
one of the most powerful ways to build a
business at least supplement your income
if you have courses and memberships of
your own
so um for
i think number one i think 50 50 is what
people should be offering i've seen a
trend recently that it's gone down to
like 30 percent maybe 40 percent 40 60.
i'm old school so i really do believe
the 50 50 model is the way to go and i
think that if you find a course that
either you've taken or you know your
students will get massive value from it
but you don't offer something like that
i think absolutely adding an affiliate
offer to the mix can supplement your
revenue like i have different streams of
revenue one of my
second biggest streams of revenue is
being an affiliate for other people
who's your biggest affiliate
um so i the most the money i the most
money i've made as an affiliate is
through marie forleo's b-school that's
why i'm really close to it
and then um
jenna kutcher and gabby bernstein are
huge and stu mclaren all three are huge
affiliates for my program digital course
academy they do really really really
well
i think we need to do that sean huh
it makes a huge difference it's like a
whole other stream of revenue
how many people work at your company
so we've got 20 full-time employees and
then some contractors on the side
everyone's virtual we do a four-day work
week and so we work monday through
thursday
and um
it feels like a big team like i feel
like that's a lot of people but i know
it's such a small business still
yeah i think that's a lot why do you why
do you need so many people
so
we do so i have three digital courses
one membership and then we do a lot of
affiliate marketing and so everybody is
just stays in their lane and like i've
got one person that's 100 focused on my
podcast so that's all she does she's
podcast producer kylie you might talk to
her your team talk to her and so we have
a lot of people in specialized roles are
you running the company and being the
front person or do you have someone help
them run the company while you're
focused on content
great question so for seven years i've
had a sidekick helping me run the
company she's a cmo and uh recently
transitioned out as a contractor so i'm
running it more than i normally do
when she's running marketing i don't
have my hands in all of that that's a
lot of work god damn
right now it feels like a lot of work
but it won't it doesn't always feel that
way what's the name of your podcast so
people who are listening can go check it
out
my podcast is online marketing made easy
how big are you guys we've been we've
been we're getting in um a pissing
contest contest with john lee dumas uh
i'm a little like i'm jealous a little
bit with uh jenna uh
jenna kutcher's totally magic like she's
got an amazing podcast how many
downloads total do you guys have um i
think in december on the podcast
platform uh we had 1.3 or
1.3 maybe million on the podcast
platform and then like another 400 on
youtube 400 000 on youtube just for the
month
yeah yeah okay well that's huge we had a
million in january that was our recent
was a million in january so wow um we've
had just just on podcast players or like
uh yes yes that's huge that's huge
so we feel good about it we've had 35
million downloads um i used to not
download twice a week changing to twice
a week has changed things for us for
sure i do a 15 minute one on tuesday and
a longer one on thursday and that
changed the game for us so i'm glad we
did that so your epis once
was that was once a week before that or
once a week before uh december i think
it was that we made the change so then
you have way more downloads prep so we
get between 50 to 100 000 probably
average we we we we have
three episodes a week sometimes so we're
doing well
that's awesome i think we even we have
four sometimes but so our so our
episodes like that the episode the
downloads per episode is the more
important metric i think uh that's the
real metric it's not the one you you
brag about but it's still new if you
actually want to grow that's the one you
care about it sounds like yours is
really big that's how you're also moving
up in the charts i mean i know that
there's like
you can't know everything about that
algorithm but one thing i've studied
enough and i'm competitive enough to
know that
i'm not moving up in the charts unless
my week of downloads are strong and so
you guys are doing better than i am
because you're always above me in the
charts i pay attention to those things
anyone who says they don't i think
they're live oh we i we totally do i
take a lot of pride in charitable
numbers but it sounds like you get more
downloads per episode than us for sure
maybe in my back catalog we do we do a
lot of um
promoting to our own community about our
podcast like we embed it in a lot of
things so um we did something really
cool in january where we had a quiz and
basically you take a quiz to figure out
where you are in your entrepreneurial
journey and then we gave you 10 episodes
that are going to help you along that
journey and that blew up so you're smart
okay gotcha you're smart and you do
smart things and then you get good
results i understand now this is the
secret
yeah
we uh the the we'll wrap up a second the
best promotion we did recently was we
just announced that we're gonna give
five thousand dollars to some person who
takes our clips and turns them into
tick-tock videos and gets popular and
tick-tock and we got i think 30 million
impressions on tick-tock in uh like 20
days
that is incredible that is super smart
that was the only smart thing we've ever
done whose idea was that one neither of
us
in fact i literally called it a dumbass
idea and on air wait does it fall
ben just popped up this is my chance to
come back into the episode yes it was my
idea
shout out to mfm cuts who is uh killing
it and and there's many others i follow
them all now on tick tock my tick tock
feet is now just clips of myself and sam
uh you know over and over again it's
great
that's awesome i'm going to check that
out wait how do i find it
yeah so here's what we did but we
screwed up or i screwed up so it's uh
what was the hashtag ben
mfm shorts
and ms
all right so
if you go on tick-tock and you search
mfm clips
with an s you'll find it but you'll also
find because i read the what we were
announcing it i accidentally one time i
said clips with an s and then i said
clip without an s so you if you if you
search both of those words
you'll find different ones and also if
you just google mfm clip you're going to
get porn because it stands for male
female male and so you'll get a whole
different
set of clips if you go to google so that
you know it's right there's something
for everybody over here we're very
inclusive
when i was just starting out my name i
think it was my maiden name now that i
think about it it was a porn star
a ballard so i think it was someone
named amy ballard was a porn star when i
uh like 13 years ago or something and i
was like mortified every time i searched
my name there she was does this sound
familiar ben
does that ring a bell
no comment ben saying no comment i see
yeah that's crazy the
yeah that sucks that definitely sucks
it's not an issue anymore
i've got a new last name i used to file
this guy on twitter named jeff f stein
um and so it could be worse
no i tweeted at that guy i was like ah
brutal name and then he got so mad at me
i was like you can't be i can't be the
first person to point this out to you
like don't be mad at me i didn't do it
to you
oh my gosh well thanks for coming on amy
this is this is awesome yeah thanks guys
so much it's nice to talk to you and i
know you guys are coming on to my
podcast so i'm looking forward to
chatting with you too sounds good take
care all right bye guys
[Music]
you